i'm not i'm not cool
like i know i am i am actually i'm very
cool you are of the three of us you are
the coolest yeah we know that yeah but i
mean you don't have to agree but it's
true absolutely because you're shocked
it is not even a question everybody okay
you know what it's really easy to be
that position of the coolest out of the
three of us
so easy first of all i'm never the cool
one so i don't even try and i think in a
weird way
that's what makes me the coolest
and you know what i'm neither or and in
a weird way that's what keeps me either
or i'm just right there in the middle
man you're always you know what the
first time i met you i was thinking this
guy's always in the middle yeah and
he'll always be either or neither nor
yeah and man you you kill it i'm a real
joseph lieberman voting kind of guy
um no one calls him joseph
hey
i want the listeners to know that we are
out here in the night in the night time
in the backyard we're making our lives
matt gourley's risking our lives yes it
took me an hour and 40 minutes to get
here i'm on my a-game and uh i was in a
hovercraft those things move that's how
fast uh i believe that the president may
have been in town today because i passed
a crazy number of motorcycle cops oh
yeah i think that's true thank you for
doing your research cool
fact checking be creative if there was a
news show and your job was to sit there
drinking and go i think that's true
they say that in the election chile's
new president will be eduardo i think
that's right i'm not joking when you
said chili's i thought you meant the
restaurant
that's that's great i'm not even you are
just trash i'm not trans you are trash
you're a little church i'm not trashed
i'm not excuse me you're feeling no pain
how about that i feel like i'm in a good
place if i drink a little more like
another glass if you were still
breastfeeding right now and you fed your
kids they'd both turn into dean martin
immediately
both your little both your little
one-year-old twins would have little
fedora
they go to breastfeed i'd look away for
a second i'd look back and they'd have
little fedoras
i think i'm gonna take another suck on
this nipple
i think i will too
you know this puts me in mine of a tune
i thought you're going to play something
no no no
where were we
where were we how can i rely on you
you're supposed to be the anchor poorly
and you're kind of messed up too well
i'm not messed up i'm drunk okay that's
fair
i want to say
that
we got your back it is nice yeah i was
skeptical about this idea first of all
because i didn't want to have to get my
passport
all the way to pasadena jesus no i'm
sorry it's just a long way to go dina
yeah yeah you look up but anyway i
figured out it's two hours ahead so i
know when to call my wife and so i get
here um and immediately i'm in a good
mood the minute i hit your house your
house is beautiful
and uh gorgeous and uh your beautiful
wife your beautiful daughter it's just
lovely and then we have this solo stove
uh right in the middle of our campfire
yeah now i solo stove does not like me
bringing them up they get embarrassed
even though they paid to be a sponsor
for this please i don't think they did
okay i didn't even know that all i'm
saying is i looked at this beautiful uh
device
which creates the perfect campfire
really perfect and there's no smoke and
very little work because ingeniously
they have little uh air ducts
just gorgeous
it's beautiful it's so it's so well
designed that even you can't screw it up
girly yeah that's true so our thanks to
the good people at solo for providing us
with this stove yeah you know what
madges did right before we started
recording he put a thing in there and
the color of the fire changed you know
what there's never been
a less
clear
definition of anything by anybody
you know you'd be great
i did that and i don't know what you
said it would be great
it would be great if
sona was present at great events in
history and had to explain what happened
ford's theater april 14th 1865. bang
what happened sona's here what is it
sona oh there was
noise
actor go fall run hat
hat man down
tyrannosaurus rex
i don't know what sauna was trying to
say is that i think there's some kind of
powder or something that you put in the
fire that made a color so solo stove
makes
color packs and there are these things
that you just throw in and then it
changes the fire into different colors
now right i'm kind of colorblind so i'd
take it on faith that these things are
cool it's said at the bottom of the pack
wasted on girly yeah
that's a lot of things manufacturers
know wasted on growing are you really
colorblind i'm red green color blind
yeah i can't i can't see red and green
when they're how is how is that how has
that do you think
changed you altered your life christmas
is a real [ __ ] because you have a gray
tree and santa's just a what does santa
just look like a gray blob to you yeah
santa just looks like i don't know like
some post-apocalyptic wanderer yeah yeah
yeah i can see red and green i just
can't see them in detailed patterns they
turn kind of brown and green stuff yeah
right okay but don't you know you didn't
bring that up right you didn't bring
that up during the interview no i didn't
because you know colors aren't really
pivotal to podcasts well
they will be
but they will be technology's changing